at the start of the campaign there was a
lot of optimism shall we say about
the uh smp getting that overall
majority you didn't manage to do it it
certainly would have made the push for a
second referendum
a bit easier wouldn't it are you
disappointed you fell short
disappointed in a historic fourth win
for the snp
no i think at the start of our campaign
you have three goals in mind one is to
win the election which we did in
spectacular fashion to increase the
number of votes you have which you've
done
more votes at this election than any
other party's ever achieved
in the devolved parliament and also more
seats we won seats the tories lost seats
labour lost seats the snp have done all
the these three things and also of
course there is
an independence majority in the
parliament so an astonishingly good
result for the snp
and i believe for scottish democracy oh
you're talking there about the
pro-independence majority
in the scottish parliament we talked
about it a lot on the show as well
um a majority of msps
support independence if you look at the
snp and scottish greens
but if you look at vote shares the
pro-independence parties
won less than 50 yourself from the
scottish greens
and the anti-referendum parties won more
than 50
so on that basis you know one person one
vote
then actually would it be democratic to
push for another referendum
this is just an absolutely bizarre
argument david cameron got around 36
percent of the vote when he took forward
a brexit referendum
of course against the wishes of people
in scotland if the
uh election we had yesterday had been
held at westminster on constituencies
we'd have a majority of about 400
so the idea that in a parliamentary
party election
you don't have a mandate when the main
party and other parties have more than
50
of the seats it really comes down to a
vote in the parliament and i didn't hear
anybody saying during all the endless
brexit votes that we had when different
parties voted for the same thing on many
occasions
that that invalidated the result this is
democracy
the snp have done extremely well we will
have a majority for
an independence referendum in the
parliament but for the first 100 days as
has been made clear by the first
minister
we'll be concentrating on the recovery
the health service education
and the health of the people in scotland
yeah it's interesting so you're talking
about focusing on
the recovery um at what point do you
start to push for another independence
referendum
the reason i'm asking this question
because it feels to me a little bit
like the timeline is slipping that it's
in nobody's interest to do it right now
including your own
is that fair when do you want to see
another referendum
i think most people in the independence
we would want to see it as soon as
possible but they also realize that
we're in the grip of a pandemic and that
is still a very real threat we've seen a
slight uptick in some areas in scotland
in recent days in terms of the
incidence of coronavirus and that's got
to be the priority for everybody i think
all the parties
have agreed on that i think it's also
true to say though that the election
we've just had was not a normal election
even though we had a fantastic increase
in turnout there wasn't the usual
hustings the public debates the town
hall meetings
and i think we all want to see when
there is to be the independence
referendum a much more full-blooded
engaged campaign on that issue so
we'll know when the public health
situation is right and the scottish
parliament will take the decision as to
exactly when that happens
and when the referendum should be can
you not give us any guidance
at all on when you think it would be the
right time to
you know push for another referendum
well i i don't think you've seen
anything different from boris johnson
mark drakeford or nicolas sturgeon
who do not predict when the end of the
pandemic is because we know how
unpredictable this disease is and also
because of the new variants as well
so it's a hostage to fortune to start
putting a time limit on that but we will
know when it's over we will know when
it's safe to have
that full bloody campaign i've mentioned
but until that happens
our concentration has to be focused on
the
pandemic making sure that we drive down
coronavirus and look after the public
health of the people in scotland
can you guarantee a referendum by the
end of 2024 as you previously said
well the only caveat to that of course
would be the pandemic but yes that's our
intention to have
that referendum i've said as soon as
possible and we're making fantastic
progress with the
pandemic in the fight against
coronavirus as you can see in the
figures now
but that threat is still there and of
course there's also the threat
of new variants of the virus so nobody
can put time limits on that is
no politician is doing that just now and
it's unreasonable i think to ask them to
do that
but at the earliest possible opportunity
when it's safe to do so we will move to
have the referendum what the one that
scotland has just voted for in massive
numbers
if boris johnson refuses to grant
another referendum or if the supreme
court finds it would be illegal because
it doesn't fall under the pound so that
the
scottish parliament to move the
legislation
what would you then do would you just
hold an independence referendum anyway
well first of all i've never believed
that boris johnson would continue to as
he would
see it veto scottish democracy after the
result of an election like the one we
had yesterday i've never believed that
would be the case
and i think you're seeing already some
changing language from the uk government
which was inevitable
it's also true to say that boris johnson
is a man that's not a stranger
to u-turns if you think about just his
manifesto at the recent election he said
he wouldn't reduce the size of the armed
forces and then promptly did
he signed an international treaty which
he then renounced pretty much as soon as
he'd signed it
so boris johnson will change to take
account of the political circumstances
in scotland
and we will proceed with the referendum
the referendum will happen it's going to
happen
i think the conservatives many of whom
have spoken to understand that's the
case
the only issue is when the time is right
and the time will be right when it's
safe to have that referendum
i understand that you know you don't
believe boris johnson but i'm not asking
you what you think boris johnson would
i'm asking what you will do
if either the supreme court says the
referendum would be you know
effective an illegal one or if boris
johnson refuses to grant it
would you hold a referendum anyway in
those circumstances
well you asked me to jump past what i
don't believe and i don't believe that
boris johnson
will as you say veto this so i don't
think that's going to happen so you're
now into hypothetical situation
and of course it wouldn't be the
scottish government to be taking legal
action scottish government will proceed
if the scottish parliament votes for the
referendum we would like to do that in
the basis of a section 30 agreement that
makes sure it's all agreed as it was
back in 2014 or previously
2012 with david cameron would like to do
it on that basis that's the right way to
do it
and i believe that will happen i think
that's what's going to happen but in the
event that there's any
denial of scottish democracy in the
event that boris johnson
johnson tries to do a trump and try and
use the legal process to subvert
scottish democracy
i believe the referendum will still
happen